um talk about just like what's next for
flagrant I always you know I I I always
like have this thing in my head where
I'm like man I would love if some of my
favorite podcasters comedians because we
always me and my boys are always talking
about how like good comedies are just
dead like I can't think of the last like
classic that's a [ __ ] that is
actually it's crazy you bring that up
because Andrew's he gets like these
Grand obsessions which are good right so
beautiful thing because he pulls it off
right now it is I want us to make a
movie yeah we do because there's no more
funny movies yeah like I I can't think
of the last like it's been at least 10
years since like there was like a super
classic yeah I mean like girls trip was
cool
um yeah Tiffany haddish
[ __ ] destroyed that movie it was such
a great movie I haven't seen that's one
of the greatest comedic performances
I've ever seen in a movie and people act
like that movie would have been good
without her it would have sucked dick
without Tiffany yeah that's probably the
last great it was like that and
bridesmaids like but like before that
what are we really talking about this is
great I Remember Loving wedding crashes
in college but that's like for weddings
that's what I mean like even if you go
back like I think it's probably like
hangover hangover super bad it's
destroyed it was probably super bad
right yeah if you really think about
like the last like yo classic comedy
yeah like Step Brothers and Step
Brothers [ __ ] Banger Step Brothers
all the Jedi Apatow joints like I just
feel like there's such a huge
just gaping whole Paws for somebody to
come through and [ __ ] put their face
in yeah yeah [ __ ] right like the
dudes from Workaholics tried to do it on
that Netflix movie but that [ __ ] was
kind of whatever yeah but I feel like if
like you guys did a movie or if you guys
could and just put all the [ __ ] sick
comedians in it like [ __ ] have Tim
Dillon play the fat funny guy you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah no that's that's the
thing that Andrew is currently like
obsessed with and yo we watched this
show you ever seen the offer I have not
heard I've heard of it though I haven't
seen it though um it's great it's a fun
show it's just all in Paramount plus
it's just it's about the making of The
Godfather
you don't realize like how much [ __ ] had
to happen for them the only thing I'm on
Paramount plus four is [ __ ]
Yellowstone but I I gotta watch it check
it out it's super fun again there's
little cheesy moments but it's just fun
and
there's a scene that makes him say I
want to do movies the main character
who's like a executive produces The
Godfather right and he leaves the
theater and he's like you don't get this
experience anywhere else he's like
sitting in a theater and this is
backward theaters or like theaters but
still that's true man as great as
YouTube is yeah it's hard to make you
feel that way nothing matches a movie
and I remember watching that and then
Andrew was talking about this
immediately like right around the same
time I was like I want to do a movie
I'll do a movie and I'm not as obsessed
as him but I'm like yo he's right man we
can create a feeling a [ __ ] Euphoria
group shared Euphoria YouTube I'm here
oh I'm here it's just me maybe one or
two other people 200 people sharing a
thing it's the closest thing you can get
to a live stand-up show no for sure or a
concert yeah yeah and like I think just
somebody has to do it if it's y'all if
it's you know have Joe Rogan just
bankroll that [ __ ] yeah that
might be the move that might be the move
yeah it just feels like man like I don't
know if it's uh uh something that goes
to theaters or not I don't know if it's
like hey we dropped a movie it's on
Amazon Prime go run that [ __ ] up or
Netflix bought the movie or whatever it
is but it just feels like yo somebody
has to step in and if and you guys have
done so many things to kind of Kick the
doors down in general just being
independent you feel like making a movie
would be you know why they don't do as
many and this might be something to try
to figure out again the team that yeah
we got a good team that could figure it
out but the problem with comedy
financing is comedy doesn't translate
internationally and international sales
are so important to movies yeah to the
studios now that's why the Avengers will
throw any money at it because
internationally everyone will watch it
comedy people aren't going to watch this
internationally most likely well also
yeah because comedy is different and
culturally yeah like the jokes that
might work here aren't going to work in
China yeah they just don't they don't
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
yeah they're like huh yeah no that's
real so it's almost harder to even get
Studios behind it so it's like what are
we doing like yeah it's it's sad though
because [ __ ] man
I I really think like the best comedy
[ __ ] is through podcasts or like series
like TV series yeah we need a good
comedy movie though we really haven't
had a great one yeah why it's been a
while man yeah 100 I was about to say
Eastbound and Down but that was a TV
show TV show
Kenny [ __ ] Powers man righteous
gemstones just yo that dude Danny
McBride just plays the same he just
plays Kenny Powers in everything and he
kills it he's [ __ ] amazing his name
is Kenny Powers
for real for real dude it's crazy man